all right the story line's got more
holes in it than swiss cheese the
dialogue is corny a lot of the criticism
is valid but i walked out of the movie
theater with a smile on my face because
i had a good time watching this movie
[Music]
here at geek culture we love our
keyboards especially with the all new
logitech mx keys mini an elegant and
functional keyboard its ultra responsive
rounded keycaps are super stable and
quiet for more productivity there are
buttons to enable dictation microphone
audio control and emojis the backlit
keys illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or 5 months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com
what's up guys it's me bobby and i'm
talking about jurassic world dominion
the final film in the jurassic franchise
the one that wraps it all up you know
the dinosaurs are living amongst us the
og cast
samuel laura der and jeff goldblum are
back with chris pratt and bryce dallas
howard and all the new characters right
this is going to be the film that brings
us all together
and it's so different now because the
dinosaurs now live with us
in our cities in our towns
and our schools and our
i mean everywhere
they live everywhere
so does the film address that
kinda
but it also relies on a lot of the same
storylines from the previous other films
and it kind of feels a bit repetitive
and that's the unfortunate part of
jurassic world dominion there was a
really interesting story to be told here
but for whatever reason it feels like
they always need to have a bad person
to
be
the you know
the scapegoat for the entire film and
it's the same thing it's like someone
who's using the dinosaurs for their own
personal benefit or greed or whatever it
may be
it's the same thing over and over again
and it feels so tiring and it's like
colin trevorrow i know you wrote this
story you know co-wrote the story but
couldn't you have thought of something
else i don't know i mean it's quite it's
frustrating because the premise was so
exciting you know when i saw the
trailers i'm like wow this looks really
cool this looks very interesting i can't
wait to see what they do with this
but within the first 20 minutes you go
okay same old ball game but i will tell
you this there is heart in this film and
that heart gives you it gives you that
spielberg vibe into it you know and a
lot of it has to do as you saw in the
trailers the clone daughter of benjamin
lockwood that uh they were hiding for
you know science reasons from the bad
people out there she gets kidnapped blue
the raptor has a baby raptor beta gets
kidnapped and so now chris pratt and
bryce dallas howard are on this
adventure to rescue
uh maisie and beta and i gotta tell you
bryce had dallas howard i love watching
her she's just so endearing she's so
beautiful she's so talented
she can do no wrong in my eyes she
directs star wars stuff i mean she
directed some of the best episodes in
the book of boba fett and mandalorian
and she's great in this as well and i i
have a crush on her right so
you can do no wrong in my eyes chris
pratt's also really good in this i mean
it's chris pratt right he's just he's
solid in every performance that he gives
and they go on this adventure and it's
very indiana jones-like and they're you
know going to foreign lands to try to
rescue these uh these two
and we get to meet the big bad of the
movie which is like evil tim cook meets
sir james dyson literally literally i
mean campbell scott the actor looks like
tim cook
and james dyson it's eerie and he kind
of has the same mannerisms as tim cook
poor tim cook you know tim's a nice guy
yeah he took our chargers out of the
iphone maybe that's why everybody's so
upset who knows i'm joking i love tim
cook but when you watch this some of
it's so on the nose you're like really
are we really going down that route are
we really creating evil tim cook but
they kind of did that um but he doesn't
own
a technology company it's not called
apple or blueberry or whatever that is
it's a it's a kind of biomedical company
again getting into all that where he's
using the dinosaurs not for something
anything evil that we know of but he's
using uh to find out about how to cure
cancer and diseases and to study their
dna but also give them a habitat to live
and live peacefully and so it's all
looks rosy on the outside but you find
out it's not all what it seems but then
you think it's going to be about
dinosaurs right but it's really not it's
about
these
not to give much away about these
evil locusts that were created
and something happened
and then you're kind of like
is this
jurassic world
with dinosaurs or are we talking about
locusts now i mean the dinosaurs are
there don't get me wrong they're there
and they show up repeatedly and it's
fun but after a few
repeated scenarios you're like do we
have seen this for how many films now
like literally the the sphere factor the
scare tactic isn't really working that
much anymore but colin trevorrow didn't
figure that one out so he keeps
repeating it over and over and over and
over again and after like
yes we know the dinosaur is about to eat
the person no the dinosaur doesn't eat
the person they get out i get it yes yes
yes repeat repeat repeat so it keeps
going on that same thing over and over
and over again which gets to be a little
bit annoying
but at the end of the day
all is well the dinosaurs live amongst
us
look how do you think it was getting in
the dinosaurs only going to die come on
there's
hundreds of thousands of them out there
no they live amongst us but um
yeah this
this film this film had a lot of
potential to be a phenomenal film and
answer a lot of questions but it
actually just relied on a lot of the old
stories of the past to sort of uh push
it forward and
i you know there's two things about this
either the script was really bad and
universal is like look we got to get it
out there so just get it made it's
during covid we're not gonna be able to
maximize a lot of things so we'll just
do the best we can or it got really
butchered in the editing room i don't
know which one it is but i do have a
feeling there's a better jurassic world
dominion film out there somewhere maybe
it's in the editing room somewhere and
i feel like
it just
some of the edits were really rough and
just they cut for convenience but it
didn't really tie in together and i mean
some of the dialogue is corny so you
can't blame it all in the editor but
yeah it's a little bit odd but i will
tell you this one of the saving graces
of this film is jeff goldblum
um you know look jeff goldblum is he's
jeff goldblum right and when he comes on
i think trevorrow just said all right
man just be you
run with it i'm just gonna hit record
and you be you and when he does that
he steals the scenes he is fantastic and
you know
i always thought it would be awesome to
have some really good scenes between
you know jeff goldblum and chris pratt
because their humor would really
complement each other you do get some
hints of that but i would love to see
more of that chemistry because
i'll tell you what there are moments
where jeff glo goldblum was just
commenting i mean you know he's just
commenting as the character when he sees
things around him because you know
you know when he was part of this
jurassic franchise obviously you know
there were trained raptors and you
didn't have a raptor trainer like you
having chris pratt's character and you
don't have you know various different
you know dinosaurs and all these things
so
he's kind of like with he's like the
audience like he kind of brings us back
to reality like how absurd this all is
and you laugh because it is hilarious
his line deliveries it's funny how he
sees things and it's just
it's og goldblum it's it's some of the
best parts of the movie so
um if you like him you're really gonna
like it when he shines in this uh laura
dern and sam neil i mean i think they're
really good but they don't give a they
don't have a lot to do in this movie
which is a bit unfortunate i mean
everybody reveres them as oh my gosh
you're these great doctors and
scientists and everything else and
everybody keeps complimenting them on
their past works but
you know
in this they just sort of
kind of make their way through it all
and it's not they're really not the
heroes of the movie i mean i kind of i
kind of feel like trevor left that for
pratt and for bryce dallas howard's
character but dewanda weiss i mean i
don't know if i'm gonna get any uh
push back on this but as i was watching
i'm thinking
she would have made a better raven and
uh obi-wan versus moses ingram i mean
moses ingram is a very talented actress
but
dewanda has this presence she has this
strength she has this
man i don't want to mess with this woman
and she's just got this
i don't know what it is man i was
watching and i'm liking wow man she just
comes alive on screen at her you know
when you watch some actresses or actors
for that matter and they just pop
whatever it is the camera loves them
they're amazing to watch
dewanda is that kind of actress
she's beautiful she's talented she's
strong she's independent you get all
this essence from her
and i'm thinking she
she would have made a better riva just
saying i don't even know if disney
auditioned her for this uh for star wars
but if they see her performance in this
they probably would have gone we need to
get her into some sort of star wars uh
uh show movie tv series i don't know
what
but she's one to watch out for i really
really liked watching her anyway uh
outside of that
yeah you know i mean it's it's a fun
movie it's a fun movie overall it's it's
not it's not without its faults there's
a lot of faults in this and if you want
to be a hardcore movie critic you can
criticize this all day long
but you're going to walk out of there
with a smile on your face and you're
going okay
the jurassic franchise is done we can
take a breather and uh you know see what
happens in the next number of years i
mean i don't think they're gonna revisit
this i don't think there's any other
stories to tell
but uh it was a good ride and uh you
know thank you steven spielberg for
bringing this to the cinemas way back
when and i can't believe it went this
many movies but uh i'm glad it's ending
now anyway those are my thoughts on
jurassic world dominion let me know your
thoughts in the comments section below
uh like always follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube be safe out
there and i'll chat to you soon